[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الغضب الروسي يشتعل اي سفينه ستمر ستصبح
هدفا مشروعا وقد اعذر من انذر وفاقنار
ترعب بولندا بالتحرك عسكري مريب على
حدودها والجيش البولندي يعلن حاله الطوارئ
والمدرعات الروسيه في بريطانيا فكيف ذهبت
الى هناك بينما لن تعلن فتح باب التجنيد
للراغبين في العمل كجواسيس وبوتين ينقذ
زعيم افريقيا من ورطه كبيره وكوريا
الجنوبيه تتسلح بالنووي الامريكي وتهدد
بالقضاء على نظام كيم جونغ اون وصيدون
امريكي ثمين يقع في يد الزعيم الكوري
وعراب السياسه الامريكيه يجتمع مع وزير
الدفاع الصيني فهل هناك صفقه دسمه تدار من
تحت الطاوله والسويد تضع حارق القران في
ورطه لا مفر منها موسكو تستخدم ورقه الموت
قالت كلمتها الاخيره والغرب بين خيارين
فاما مطرقه الجوع او سندان الكرملين واما
ان حاولت دوله ان تغرق الحظر على تصدير
الحبوب في البحر الاسود فهناك تتغير
اللهجه الروسيه لتعلنها وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه انه بدءا من منتصف ليل العشرين من
يوليو سيتم التعامل مع جميع السفن المبحره
في البحر الاسود الى الموانئ الاوكرانيه
على انها تنقل معدات عسكريه
لقواتك وبالتالي فهي اهداف عسكريه مشروعه
لقوات موسكو فمن يتجرا على اغضاب الدب
الروسي وكان التهديد بالكلام لا يكفيه
لتبدا موسكو باول هجوم عملي بالامس لتكرره
اليوم ايضا حيث قال وزير الزراعه
الاوكراني ان جزءا كبيرا من البنيه
التحتيه لتصدير الحبوب في ميناء تشيرنو
مورس بمنطقه اوديسا تضرر جراء هجوم روسي
واضاف الوزير ان الهجوم دمر ايضا 60 الف
طن من الحبوب في الميناء كان من المفترض
تحميلها وشحنها وفق اتفاق تصدير الحبوب
عبر البحر الاسود قبل 60 يوما اذا كان
الموعد قبل 60 يوما فلن كل هذا التاخير يا
هذا ضربات كهذه كانت قد بثت الرعب في دوله
جنوب افريقيا حيث ستعقد قمه مجموعه بريكس
ليعلنها رئيس جنوب افريقيا
بان اعتقال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
سيكون بمثابه اعلان حرب على روسيا مضيفا
انه لن يخاطر بتوريط بلاده بالحرب مع
روسيا فمن واجبه حمايه البلاد وفق تعبيره
لينقذ بوتين رامبوزا في اللحظه الاخيره
ويخرجه من هذه الورطه وذلك باعلانه انه
سيحضر القمه عن بعد عبر تقنيه الاتصال
بالفيديو ويدار ما دخلتشر وبالعوده الى
اوكرانيا كانت قياد قد اكدت انها شنت
عمليه ناجحه ذلك بعد اندلاع حريق في ميدان
تدريب عسكري في شبه جزيره القرم ما تسبب
في انفجارات عنيفه دفعت السلطات المعنيه
من جانب روسيا الى اجلاء سكان اربع بلدات
متاخمه لموقع الحريق واغلاق طريق تفريد
السريع وعلى حين غره وفي خضم هذه المعارك
الضاريه في اوكرانيا استغلت بريطانيا
الودعه لتحقق غايه مهمه هناك حيث فجر رئيس
الاركان البريطاني الادمر توني بارك
مفاجئه بقوله ان قواتي بلاده فككت اليات
ومدرعات روسيه استولت عليها اوكرانيا خلال
الحرب وذلك حتى تتعلم لندن كيف تدافع عن
نفسها ازاء اي هجوم مستقبلي ونحن نتصفح
الخبر الذي نشره المصدر في شبكه
لكن انه اوقفتم المدرعات فكيف ستوقفون
صواريخ
المرعب يا احفاد اليزابيث لندن لم تكتفي
بالمدرعات لتتجه نحو ما هو اخطر وذلك
بدعوتها بشكل صريح لجذب جواسيس في روسيا
للمساعده في انهاء حرب اوكرانيا حيث
استخدم رئيس الاستخبارات البريطانيه
لاتخاذ موقف ضد النظام الروسي وتبادل
الاسرار مع المخابرات البريطانيه فهل يقبل
الروس ببيع بلادهم للبريطانيين وهنا الحرب
والمعارك وليس سواها هي ما سيعلن الانتصار
لهذا الطرف او ذاك لتعلن الدفاع الروسي
انها نفذت ضربات وصفتها بالانتقاميه على
مدينتين
في اوكرانيا مثيره الى انها استهدفت مواقع
في اوديسا تم استخدامها لتجهيز قوارب
مسيره لتنفيذ هجمات ضد روسيا والتحضير
لهجوم على جسر واضافت الوزاره ان قوتها
تقدمت باكثر من كيلو مترين باتجاه كوبيانس
شرقي اوكرانيا بينما قال متحدث باسم قياده
المنطقه الشرقيه الاوكرانيه ان الجيش
الروسي حشد اكثر من 100 الف جندي اكثر من
900 دبابه في المنطقه لمحاوله ايقاف تقدم
القوات الاوكرانيه فيا له من جيش كبير هل
العدد حقيقيا انك تريد ابتلاع المزيد من
الدعم الغربي كوم المصدر
متحدث باسم قياده المنطقه الشرقيه
الاوكرانيه قال ان الجيش الروسي حشد اكثر
من 100 الف جندي واكثر من 900 دبابه في
المنطقه وليس ذلك فحسب بل ان الدفاع
الروسي اعلنت احباط محاوله اوكرانيا
لتنفيذ هجوم بواسطه 28 طائره مسيره على
اهداف في شبه جزيره القرن الليله الماضيه
موضحه ان انظمه الدفاع الجوي دمرت سبعه
عشره مسيره بوسائط الدفاع الجوي بينما تم
تعطيل احدى عشره مسيره اخرى بوسائط الحرب
الالكترونيه فاسقطت دون ان تصل الى
اهدافها وبعد كل هذه الضربات الروسيه ها
هو الاتحاد الاوروبي يعد خطه دعم عسكري
لاوكرانيا بما في ذلك توريد الاسلحه
والتدريب العسكري بقيمه 20 مليار يورو على
مدى السنوات الاربع المقبله وذلك بحسب
صحيفه بوليتيكو اربع سنوات يا هؤلاء وعن
ستستمر كل هذه المده هي لبالكم الطويل
واول الغيث الاوروبي قطره هولنديه حيث
اعلنت وزيره الدفاع الهولنديه كايساءلون
ان امستردام سترسل الى اوكرانيا قريبا
ناقلات جند المدرعه من
طرازاحها في البلاد ومن اوكرانيا الى
الجاره بولندا التي بدات تحس بخطر يلوح في
الافق وذلك بعد وصول عناصر مجموعه باجنر
العسكريه الروسيه الى بيلاروسيا ليعلن
وزير الدفاع بولندا ماريوش جاك نشرا
لوائين عسكريين على الحدود الشرقيه للبلاد
على ذكر مجموعه فاجنر فقد ظهر فيديو مسرب
لقائد المجموعه
يخاطب مقاتله قائلا لن نقاتل في اوكرانيا
مطالبا اياهم بالاستعداد للذهاب لافريقيا
الاحداث والتطورات
السويد ترفع يدها عن حرق القران الكريم
العراقي سلوان موميكا ليستغيث هذا الاخير
سحبت مني الحمايه وهددتني بملف لجوء
ورمتني امام المسلمين اعلنت الولايات
المتحده وصول غواصه امريكيه مزوده بصواريخ
باليستيه
الى كوريا الجنوبيه للمره الاولى منذ عقود
وهو امر طال انتظاره من جانب سيول وذلك
لتنسيق الاستجابه في حال اندلاع حرب نوويه
مع كوريا الشماليه رد بيونغي لم يتاخر حيث
اطلقت صاروخين بالستيني المدى باتجاه بحر
الشرق وذلك بعد يومين من اصول الغواصه
النوويه الامريكيه الى الجاره الجنوبيه
ولا زلنا في احداث شبه الجزيره الكوريه
هنا وعلى غير العاده حدث شيء غير متوقع
ولم يكن في حسبان واشنطن حيث قال مسؤولون
امريكيون ان جنديا امري
الى كوريا الشماليه ويعتقد انه محتجز لدى
مما تسبب في ازمه جديده بواشنطن مع الدوله
المسلحه نوويا فكيف سيستغل كم هذا الجندي
قدر وزير الدفاع البريطاني
ما اعتبره وعدم وجود الخبره العسكريه لدى
الصين مشيرا الى ان ذلك يهدد استقرار
النظام السياسي العالمي في ظل سياسات بكين
الراهنه والى بكين وفي وقت تشهد العلاقات
الامريكيه الصينيه توترات كبيره اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع الصينيه ان عراب امريكا
اجتمع بوزير الدفاع الصين الثلاثاء الماضي
وواشنطن تقول ان العراب ذهب الى بكين
كمواطن عادي فما الذي يدار من تحت الطاوله
يا هؤلاء هذا ما ستكشفه لنا الايام
القادمه
[موسيقى]